>>Teacher: All right, if you still
need to record, your books are
in this little closet
right over here, so--
>>Narrator: One of the
key ingredients to success
at YES Prep North Central, is
the caliber of the teachers here.
>>Teacher: Any questions before I--
>>Chris: YES was founded by teachers.
We wanted to create an organization
that was going to be able
to be a good place
for teachers to work,
where teachers could have a
voice in how the school was run,
that it was a place where every
decision was made in the interest
of what's going to be great
for kids and teachers.
>>Rachel: Talk about
that with your table.
What are the problems
that might come up.
>>Jeremy: We know that teachers
are the single greatest factor
in the achievement of
a low income students.
And so if we can go
out there and make sure
that we find a great teacher
for every single classroom,
then we will be able to continue
to send 100 percent of
our kids to college.
>>Teacher: Like, what
is this poem about?
Don't worry about--
>>Narrator: In order to build a
great team, YES Prep developed a list
of traits that they are looking
for in the teachers they hire.
>>Mark: We hired an outside
organization to come in and look
at our teachers and find out,
like, what are the traits
that really represent our highest
performing teachers, and then we look
at those traits when we
interview, and we try and make sure
that thank you people we bring in
have each of those seven traits.
>>Narrator: The traits
include, rebound time.
>>Mark: How quickly our teachers,
after a setback, bounce back,
and are ready to keep going.
>>Narrator: Energy mode.
>>Jeremy: Because we have a longer
school day, and a longer school year,
our teachers are going to have
to sustain energy and passion
over an entire school year.
>>Teacher: Get down,
get down, get down.
>>Narrator: Taking charge.
>>Mark: We're looking
for teachers as leaders.
They don't see themselves as just
teachers, they're people who see
that classroom as an
opportunity to lead.
>>Narrator: Agreement.
>>Jeremy: Well, we're not looking
for somebody who just wants
to shut their door
and teach those kids,
we're looking for somebody who's
going to go across the hallway
or across the grade level, to have
conversations with other teachers.
>>Teacher: And I'm sure we
can probably collaborate
and share challenges on this, too.
>>Narrator: Perfectionism.
>>Teacher: I think
it's really important
that they aren't ever
satisfied with 99.9 percent.
We're looking for the
100 percent every day.
>>Narrator: The other
traits are, drive,
which entails the continual setting
and achievement of personal goals,
and reserve, which YES calls the
ability to share their opinions.
>>Teacher: I liked when we
had time to work on things.
>>Teacher: And again,
this is just proposed.
No decisions have been made,
but it's the time of the year
to do these things, because we
have to finalize the schedule,
actually within the
next couple of weeks.
>>Narrator: To balance the longer
work days and high expectations,
the administration built
a support structure
to ensure the teachers have
the resources they need.
>>Craig: Burn out is something we
have to deal with, but we work hard
as administrators to find ways
to relieve teachers and try
and provide some balance in a
job that's inherently unbalanced.
>>Philip: Maybe if we could just
take five minutes on our own,
and just write some thoughts
on the pros and cons.
>>Narrator: YES Prep's support
system includes a full time Dean
of Instruction, who directs
professional development.
>>Teacher: I want you to
read the first paragraph.
>>Narrator: Michelle LaFlure,
observes a classroom instruction,
and gives feedback to veterans
and new teachers alike.
>>Michelle: We have a pretty
intensive rubric that we use,
so I go into every classroom
approximately five times a year.
The majority of my time is spent
observing and debriefing with them.
>>And after we talk
about high expectations
for this particular lesson,
then we'll go into student
centered classroom, which is--
>>We want to give them a
comprehensive evaluation,
not just one that's solely based
on instruction, and so we look
at instruction, management,
assessments, planning--
>>There's some key takeaways so that
you can write down key takeaways
from this meeting, and then we'll
establish some action steps also.
>>Narrator: Teachers also have
nearly two hours each day for team
and grade level planning meetings
during the extended school day.
>>Teacher: Tuesday, you are doing,
What is Poetry, and
the Go Inside poem.
>>Michelle: Having that
common planning time,
just enhances the collaboration among
the team, but also, great minds,
when they work together, are
able to accomplish so much more
than just an isolated
individual, working on something.
>>Katie: I know we talked about you
maybe writing poems for the lesson.
Do you still want to do some of that?
>>With the team teaching
relationship,
we're looking for possible
points of integration,
but I also have planning time
with the other seventh
grade English teacher,
so we're teaching the same thing.
So at that point, we're
dividing up relationships,
and we can literally do double the
work, because we split up things
like lesson plans, making
projects, organizing exhibition.
>>Narrator: There's no
top down management here.
All YES Prep teachers have a
voice in setting school policies,
which results in a vibrant
energetic democracy.
>>Teacher: It would be great if
we actually voted as a staff,
of the things that we want to learn
and then make those into goals.
>>Jeremy: You know, it's challenging
for me, sometimes, as a leader,
because your tendency is to want
to keep control of everything.
And the more that I sort of
keep the authority to myself,
and keep the decision making to
myself, the more likely our school is
to become stagnant, and just
become basically a microcosm of me,
and that's the last
thing I would want.
And so I intentionally hire
people who are different from me,
I intentionally look for ways to
have people in my school who push me.
>>Teacher: That way, by the
end of the year, every teacher,
at least once, got to go to
exactly what they needed to.
>>Jeremy: We also have a weekly
early dismissal on Wednesdays,
where teachers gather to do
professional development,
and sometimes we'll do something
fun, like have a staff game,
or a staff picnic, or a staff
barbecue, just something
to continually draw on our strength
of relationships with each other.
>>All: [cheers, applause]
>>Michelle: I'm going to have
you guys reflect a little bit
individually about what worked
and what didn't work so well.
And then we'll have a discussion,
to kind of come away with some ideas
for things that can change for next--
>>Narrator: The structured
teamwork and support at YES Prep,
enhances camaraderie
and mutual respect.
>>Michelle: So if you have any
ideas, you can e-mail Mark.
>>Katie: I love the
freedom that I'm given here.
I love the fact that
the sky's the limit.
I mean, there's literally no end
to what I can accomplish here.
I feel like there's
leadership opportunities for me,
I feel like there is support,
there's people I love,
and so I'm exhausted all the time.
I mean, it's a really,
really hard job,
but I am always driven to do more.
>>Craig: And a quarter of
a clap for Peck, one-two--
>>Narrator: At the end of each
long week, the staff gets together
for shout outs, to acknowledge
their hard work and collaborations
that go beyond the call of duty.
>>Teacher: So Holly was
planning portfolios,
getting stuff ready
for the Spring trip--
>>Craig: At first,
the staff was like,
why are we doing this,
this is kind of strange.
But for me, it is one of
the highlights of the week.
It is fun on Fridays to get
together after a grueling week,
which it is here at YES,
to shout each other out.
>>Teacher: She's been able to
juggle a thousand different things.
>>Craig: And they range
anywhere from, you know,
I want to thank so-and-so,
for covering my class
when I had a Parent come in,
to, I want to thank so-and-so
for bringing me a cup of coffee
this morning, I really needed it.
>>Craig: Two claps and a
train for Holly, one-two.
>>All: [clapping] Choo-choo,
come on, ride it.
>>Teacher: The students
now have adopted it.
Every grade level does
the exact same thing,
and not only the North
Central Campus,
but some of the other YES
schools have adopted this idea
of the two claps for.
>>Teacher: And I just think that's
true of pretty much everyone
in this room, that, every
time I see Craig, I'm uplifted
and excited, and thank you for that.
>>Craig: Two claps and a bow for me.
One-two [clapping].
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.